her calls for refreshing and fun
cocktails and beautiful colors look at
this verse
so let's welcome francesco la franconi
of carver steak to show us how to do
these fresh cocktails the right way
how to do them the right way right
because you know you can fresh means
straight from the garden yes thank you
very much for having us uh here from
kirbystick we're very excited to promote
2022 summer specialty seasonal cocktails
and you designed this menu yes and i
wanted to share with you
some of the drinks uh because we don't
have a lot of time to prepare but i'm
going to make only one in the meantime
we do have a delicious apparel spritzer
which is very trendy it's made with the
mionetto prosecco these are the summer
drinks and we just top it off a little
more shine blush in paloma summer trail
and that's the one yes and this one is
actually the applicat
alfresco okay it's a bourbon-based drink
with a
fresh apricot puree
and a russell bourbon bit
when are we making it
a little bit
a little bit here nothing like coming
me neither okay
beautiful we're gonna make when you
smell you smell that rosemary these um
because it's all about the your
cocktails are all about sweet and the
scents right
a curvy steak we do have a beautiful
patio that accommodates uh
over 150 seats and actually we do have a
patio garden uh curated by resorts world
horticulture department so we have
a great variety of flavors and herbs
from lemon verbena and so forth so this
one i'm going to put it here is also the
watermelon crush you're making all these
beautiful
gregory's watermelon essence and
and also
that's the one and this one is also
beautiful
this one is with the american harvest
vodka it's called the summer trail
because when you walk the summer you
come across butterflies and beautiful
flowers so this one is with a vodka and
elderflower liqueur
and i can put one more here and then i
am going to make a put up so one more
for you okay let's do it this is called
irish and cups because these are
both hands are taken so irish handcuffs
yes
oh my god this is delicious you know
what again it's that sweetness it's the
scent as you drink it you smell the
freshness as well and for people going
people going um people at home who have
their own herb gardens this is a really
good idea for them as well right totally
so because your drinks really stand out
there is a maria like you have a
peppermint spearmint you have lemon
verbena i mean this is incredible uh if
you smell like rub it through your
finger a little bit and smell the lemon
scent okay while i do that let's make
the drink and then uh
this one we're gonna squeeze uh
you're gonna make me wanna have a garden
not have no green thumb it's uh me
neither that's why i have the ortho
culture department taking care of you
right that's why you come to cairo stay
for this beautiful you know seasonal
summer cocktails and uh smelling this
francisco this one uh we're gonna give a
little bit of our modeling to dissolve
the roses marmalade why you do that can
we explain what this is because this is
very unique so everybody's familiar with
rose's cordial line to make the gimlet
gin or vodka gimlet in this case we are
going to have fresh lime simulated with
a
lime marmalade and some lime bitters
and then some limoncello from italy
on the beautiful amalfi coast wow did
you scream summer on its own you keep it
in the freezer and sip it after dinner
or before dinner or any hour of the day
time so we're going to put a little bit
of this any time and then uh chartreuse
130 herbs blended in a secret formula
beautiful from 1605 guys are taking
notes over there so equal parts about
half pounds and then this is a tanqueray
gene everybody's familiar with tanqueray
but this one is a from
seville oranges from spain so it's
flavor it's sweet as a little orange so
it's so complex what we do
basically is going to be
shaking all these ingredients together
let's do it
shake it don't fake it
that's right that's right
shake it too a little bit okay it will
taste better
perfect wow you got the style are you
looking for a shifter carbon stock
though maybe actually so i get free
drinks yes all right sold
so we have a beautiful ice cream
ice is very important here very
important because it might compromise
the texture of the drink so now
we have the
rosy slime marmalade
right everything and then what we are
going to do also i know the underneath
here
it's a beautiful summer cherries we
really is a little zest could you hold
this and so we can show of course the
beautiful
says like that
just to burst the flavors lime zest and
then we take a little bit of verbena the
one that you had the pleasure to smell
earlier and uh now verbena is this the
one where if you if you taste it it kind
of
creates
an interesting flavor numbs your tongue
a little bit no
but perhaps uh maybe it's the very
strong power for the zesty lamb on there
okay might cause that but this is called
the hello sunshine wow look at that okay
here we go
think of a gimlet
in a caravan steak we also make it with
vodka
which we use grigor's has he thrown for
that so a little more citrus uh wow
and this is it our beautiful summer
cocktail it's delicious thank you well
it's dangerous because i'm about to i
can just gulp this down all right
i'll toast with the spritzer carver's
steak at resorts world thank you so much
thank you
we're looking forward to have you in
this beautiful new steakhouse that is
our world and there you go thank you and
remember we're not drinking we're
learning i like that